[Music]
the idea that
time is an illusion is something that
philosophers have wondered about
for two and a half thousand years so
time basically can go
backwards and forwards if you look at
the microscopic equation so there must
be another reason
why it appears to go forward and so
actually what we should expect is there
to be quite a complicated story
of how it is that for creatures like us
receiving time
we end up perceiving it in the way that
we do even if it might look quite
different
at the fundamental level
people who think about time as being
static they're just
missing out on this fundamental feature
of the world
the idea that time is an illusion
is something that philosophers have
wondered about for two and a half
thousand years
the idea that time is just an appearance
and not just
time that change is just an appearance
was worried about back with the
pre-socratics
what is quite new relatively
is the idea that now that the present
moment
might or might not be an illusion so i
think
that about 100 years ago people who
thought that time was real
conceived time to be static
a kind of block universe in which past
present future are all real and they saw
time as kind of like a fourth dimension
of space
so in the same way that in space you can
move in any direction
and no direction is privileged i think
people thought the same about time
and there were various reasons why that
was so
so things like timelines had become
really popular
they were invented in 1765 the very idea
of plotting events on a timeline is
something that's quite new
and as soon as you start to think about
events on a line
you have something that's static a line
is something that
doesn't move and i think that's one of
the things that led people to think
about time
is a static dimension
what you then get in late 19th early
20th century
is an absolute rebellion against this
idea so
people like that henry bergson in france
and arthur eddington in britain began
saying no no if you think that there's
that time is just like space then it
means that there's nothing special about
the present moment
there's no now that's ever moving ever
flowing forwards
you just have moments of time
spread out and there's nothing special
about
now and they really disliked that view
they thought that
on the contrary there is something
really special about the present that we
feel time flowing and moving forwards
and and that people who think about time
as being static and the present as just
being an illusion
that they're just missing out on this
fundamental feature of the world
right so i think this is how this debate
got started whether or not the presence
is an illusion i think it all kicked off
about 100 years ago
why would time not be real
time refers to duration that is
experienced change everything you see
around you is constantly changing even
if you move your head that's change
and even if you don't if you see
complete blackness
there's still change in terms of
accumulation of memory
so you can't avoid duration in in one
well
in prosaic consciousness and everyday
consciousness duration is part of
um lived experience so that's the most
common um
notion of time of course time itself in
that sense then
when i say time it's an abstraction from
duration so
um the the real thing we experience is
the change the you know the perception
of the change of
of things of of and of our mind
and from that whole
um experience we sort of extract
um the abstraction that is time
and then often you know in physics
especially we put time on a timeline
an abstracted spatial representation of
time
secondly we must distinguish when we
talk about time
uh the triplicity that is past
present and future uh this is the
essence of time according to jeremy
mctaggart
it was british um idealist
at cambridge um he wrote this great text
in 1908 published in 1908 called the
unreality of time
where he argues that the past present
and future
which is the essence of time is merely
subjective it can't really be properties
of events themselves
because they couldn't have all those
three attributes at once
in physics and science there is no such
thing as the present
moment as compared to the past and the
future the present moment is determined
by the mind itself
so you take away the mind and you've
taken away that
fundamental aspect of time itself
um what are you left with well you can
still talk about the order of events
c series as mctaggart calls it um which
are not subjective but objective
so you know first a happens and b then c
and d then e and so on so forth
another aspect of time very important is
what william james
called the species present the species
present
the length of the present moment and now
is very much determined again by
our minds and it can extend and it can
contract
um related to that
is what henry bergson calls the rhythm
of duration
or the speed of time um
and uh even this is uh very subjective
which means that um speed of change can
speed of time rather can change
according to
one's predicament humans predicament but
also according to species so
um there is evidence that different
species perceive time
faster or slower than we do for example
a fly
might perceive our um whacking of it
um in slow motion unfortunately fourthly
we can consider time as the fourth
spatial dimension
uh vis-a-vis minkowski and einstein
minkowski was einstein's mathematics
teacher
um and
i mean there was before before then
before you know 1905 when the theory of
first theory of relativity came out
there were um there were
good mathematical theories as to
why there were more than three spatial
dimensions um something really from
riemann who proved that um you can have
a geometry based on
uh multiple dimensions of space not just
the three that we presuppose i mean
aristotle said that
you know um physicality is
three-dimensional that's just
it there cannot possibly be more without
contradiction
but this seemed to be at least
theoretically mathematically
not right so riemann proved that you can
get very coherent
geometries then based on four dimensions
five
um ad infinitum minkowski einstein
uh heralding the theory of relativity
said that times the fourth spatial
dimension
uh this was you know this is still
controversial of course i mean
spatial dimensions are unidirectional
you go left and right up and down
forward and backwards of course but you
can't go
backwards in time it seems time seems to
be a one-way dimension
there has been proof that um
one's velocity in space affects the
speed of time so the faster you go
the slower time goes relative to other
times and also
interestingly then with gravity the
closer you are to a gravitational point
the faster time goes as well time
doesn't really exist and this is an
emergence of time
that actually comes from a quantum
mechanical description yes time is a
mysterious property of our world around
us we experience it
i'm gonna talk about it as a theoretical
physicist i'm not a philosopher
so let me first explain what time means
in physics and then i'll go
indeed further into my recent ideas
about why
time might emerge from so in physics
we think about time as evolving forward
we even use it that way we use the past
to determine the state of the present
and then
we have a logical way in which events
occur
we call this causality in the sense that
we have cause and effect
where cause precedes the effect and you
cannot change this
around there's also a very intimate
connection between time and space this
is in
in relativity where we can even
transform
time and space into each other so
there's no absolute meaning of time when
you start moving around
clocks work differently depending on
your velocity
so what determines the direction of time
there are some ideas that
related to entropy because entropy is a
notion that
you say has to increase towards the
future and then maybe we should say that
the direction of time is determined by
entropy i think that's a
a misconception because i think
microscopically
the laws are time symmetric and you can
derive
this law of the second law of
thermodynamics which
implies the the increase of entropy
from these microscopic laws which are
reversible so
time basically can go backwards and
forwards if you look at the microscopic
equation so there must be another reason
why it appears to go forward
then there's the idea that maybe that if
i really know what's
the state today can i calculate what's
going on
tomorrow is there a determinism can i
really determine what is
the next state in physics many people
believe this that when we
know the microscopic laws then we can
compute everything i don't think that's
possible
that's sort of a local way of
determinism that is
going too far i think nature is
fundamentally
non-local that means that we have to
really know the entire state to know
what the future is
and it's also quantum mechanical and
this is where i think my
ideas are sort of coming from is that
the way we are thinking about
the universe should be in terms of
quantum mechanics and then even we can
understand
the nature of space and time in a
different way so those are the recent
ideas we've
been developing together with colleagues
we've looked at
what happens near horizon so horizon is
a space
part of space where clocks can even slow
down so that they appear to be sort of
no time left
so this is where we can understand
better where time comes from
and then the following picture appears
so
in quantum mechanics we can start from a
state
where there's no time you simply know
the state of the system
but then the way the time appears is if
you are
asking questions about only the things
that we can see
what like the visible part of the
universe but they're also part that we
cannot see
and then we have ignored that part and
then suddenly what happens is that
in our world in our perception time
appears
but it's relative to the part that we
cannot see so time appears to
flow forward because there's another
part
of the whole microscopic world where it
sort of appears to go the other way
the other way and this is an emergence
of time
that actually comes from a quantum
mechanical description so
microscopically i really believe that
time doesn't really exist
so it's something that we have invented
or at least used in our
daily experience but if you ask me does
the
real microscopic universe know what time
is probably not
but we have something in place uh
that that eventually can sort of form a
microscopic language tell us what time
then is how it appears
so this is called the theory of
emergence that's really
the idea that things that we are using
in our common language
are not really meaningful at the
microscopic scale
so time is also one of those those
notions
so eventually i think can we really ask
answer the question what time is i think
that's a difficult one i mean even the
beginning of time like the big bang i
think is a
question that is going to be well
central to all of
understanding what time is but it's
going to be a long time before we have
answered those questions in space time
there are
fundamentally three different types of
directions the future directed the past
directed and the baseline
directed i think we feel it's going
forward because it is
in space there really is no preferred
directionality if you you imagine in a
three-dimensional
euclidean space you have arrows pointing
all different ways and
and they don't you you wouldn't know
even what to make if someone asked well
which way is space going it's not going
anywhere you know but even
in relativity when we got rid of this
absolute simultaneity
uh you have these light this light cone
structure and
that structure divides directions in
space
time into different classes you have the
future light cone and you have all these
directions that are as we're pointing
to the future you have the past light
cone and you have all these directions
that are pointing to the past
and you you can't rotate from down here
to up here
without going through the whole outside
bit right the whole
outside bit which is connected points in
what we call space-like directions
so just that structure says yeah in
space-time there are fundamentally
three different types of directions the
future directed the past directed and
the
as it were space like directed and
one obvious explanation for that is
because time
is an intrinsically directed quantity it
has a direction to it
and i think a lot of the confusion comes
because
the mathematics that had been developed
to understand spatial structure was very
powerful and new and interesting and if
you're a mathematician or physicist you
learn a lot about that
but that was developed to describe space
and there is no intrinsic directionality
to space and then when it came to trying
to describe
space time the natural thing to do was
to pull off the shelf
this mathematics that was already there
and use it which is what people did and
then they looked and they said but
there's no direction in there
but that's just a kind of failure in the
mathematics it's pretty easy to solve
that and
to develop a mathematical structure for
describing intrinsically directed
quantities
like time here i see a big role for
physics as well as psychology
in explaining how we are going to think
of time as something
special there's a lot of speculations
about how we're going to come up with a
final theory
particularly one that can put together
what we're learning about space time
from general relativity
and what's happening at the quantum
mechanical level
nevertheless when it comes to talking
about uh
people at the kind of energy and length
scales and what's going on at the kind
of
environments that we inhabit we know
pretty much how that story looks
um and in the kind of physics we're
using in this setting
there doesn't seem to be a lot of the
parts of the intuitive package
of time that he was just talking about
so these kinds of physics they don't
indicate a special moment that's present
they don't discuss a flow of time
and they don't have an intrinsic
direction to time itself
one could take that as a reason to think
that the science is incomplete or
missing something
fundamental but i guess my view is part
of a trend recently to think that's not
the right way of reading the situation
it would be a big surprise if our direct
experience of the world
could deliver what things are actually
like at the fundamental level
and so actually what we should expect is
there to be quite a complicated story
of how it is that uh for creatures like
us
perceiving time we end up perceiving it
in the way that we do
even if it might look quite different at
the fundamental level
so here i see a big role for physics as
well as psychology
and explaining how given the kind of
interests and concerns we have
we are going to think of something time
as something special
having these features james mentioned
the block universe i think it might be
worth having that on the table so
according to the picture of science that
works by and large
for us we can think of events
in the past and future as just as real
as the events now
we can sort of line them up uh in these
kind of spatial layers with time as one
dimension and space as the other three
dimensions
and all parts of the block are equally
as real as each other
no moment is privileged as what is
objectively now
time is in a sense a little bit like
space in that just as you can refer to
here and you mean
wherever you mean where from where
you're standing and i can say here and i
mean something different but we're not
as it were having a deep disagreement
similarly there aren't special moments
of time
uh if i say now it just means the moment
where i'm speaking you can say now two
minutes later you just mean a different
moment
there is quite a different way of
thinking about space time which is much
more like newtonian dynamics
there is an alternative way of thinking
about time
a space time where you don't think of it
as a block that's given
once and for all or even that it's
growing which i think is we could talk
about that because a lot of people who
think it's growing now
believe that this collapse of the wave
function is causing it to grow which i
think is very questionable
there is quite a different way of
thinking about space-time which is much
more like newtonian dynamics
where basically you can think about it
as being
one strong three-dimensional structure
another one like that another one like
that
and they are put together so you put you
put the one triangle
relative to the other in which the
difference between them is reduced to a
minimum
so you can stack one like that so the
next three dimensional structure you put
it on top of that
and then and then you put it in a
certain separation from it
which is a measure of the amount of
difference between them at each point
that's duration that's that's where
you're getting duration out of
difference
and you go on building up like that once
you've built up space time like that
you can cut it in any way you like or
you can travel through it in any way you
like hidden in this wonderful structure
that einstein discovered there might be
a unique way of defining a simultaneity
within einstein's general theory of
relativity not a special theory of
relativity
and it's very very beautiful because in
three-dimensional space
you know how beautiful a soap bubble is
it has what's called
constant mean curvature the curvature of
the soap bubble is always perfect
and this very special way that may and
quite a lot of relativists take this
seriously that may exist in space
time is analogous to soap bubbles in
four dimensions
and that's called constant mean
curvature foliation if you want the
technical word so
i would say there may after all be a
notion of a simultaneity but watch
whichever way you cut that
loaf of bread if you cut it through that
way you will always get a
three-dimensional structure
so i think my notion of a now survives
even then
and i think it will also survive in any
quantum theory of the universe or at
least i think there's a reasonable
chance
our belief that there is something like
a time dimension and that nature has
something like time in it nobody here is
disputing
i take it that that we naively all do
feel we have a direct
experiential experience of time flowing
yeah don't we sure whether that's
evidence for something in fundamental
physics
is a different thing you are then
brought back to this notion of either we
have to say to people
i know that's how it feels but for some
weird reason it's not true
which from an evolutionary point of view
is very odd because evolution doesn't
usually
successful creatures who have evolved
don't usually believe something that's
false
but this this belief that i mean hang on
our belief that that we
that there is something like a time
dimension and that nature has
something like time in it obviously
that's nobody who is disputing
that it's the idea that the way that we
experience that time dimension and the
fact that it's very different from the
way that we experience the spatial
dimension
does that piece of evidence give us
reason to think that
not only does time play a slightly
different role in our physics but does
it have this completely different
metaphysical character
it's not laid out like the other
dimensions exactly and that's the
question here so it's not that we'll be
completely mistaken about our
ideas about time if the eternalist is
correct
um it's just whether this one bit of our
experience is really something that's
there in the fundamental reality
or whether like many many aspects of our
experience that we brought up earlier
um it's actually some kind of product of
the kinds of creatures we are
and the way that we interact with the
world if the eternalists are correct
what does correct mean
so i have a um so i suppose
i actually have trouble with this debate
because i have a lot of trouble
understanding what the alternative i
understand what it is to sort of say
look everything everything we're
positing in physics it's all real
and that's fine and all of these facts
that we're predicting and if they're
correct they're they're all real
i have a lot of trouble understanding uh
what it is to say only one subset of
those facts namely the ones that are
happening right now are real which is
the presenters claim so
so i have a so so i can i can only
present the eternalist viewers as the
one that i
understand which is just the common you
know dinosaurs they're real they're not
at the same time as us
and you know i mean space travel's real
it's not at the same time as us either
um but there's no there's no sort of
special status apart from being at
different times those things have but i
don't know what a non-eternalist is
but whoever he is he doesn't disagree
with dinosaurs
no he says but he says it's very
important that they did exist and that
that's a different fact
from the fact that i say they exist kind
of tenselessly but
but in the past but at a different time
from me and i think someone like lee
needs to think that there's something
very special about saying that the
dinosaurs
don't now exist and they did exist
you're sort of expressing some some fact
that goes beyond just the fact that
there is temporal distance from me
for more debates talks and interviews
subscribe
today to the institute of art and ideas
at iai tv
you